[Music]
on this thursday night the concern of
omicron spreading in schools
about half the country's kids will be
back in class next week while the others
get an extended break our kids need to
be able to go to school leaving some
parents scrambling again
the hit to health care how provinces
plan to react as more and more frontline
staff test positive across the country
omicron's surging in western europe in
france more than two people are infected
every second while russia's pandemic
death toll climbs
and a dog's life i can't believe someone
didn't love him enough to keep him two
fat fighters in edmonton get the gift of
health
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
tonight with the record-breaking impact
of covet 19. for the first time since
the pandemic began the number of daily
new cases worldwide has surpassed 1
million in canada skyrocketing case
counts reached new highs in several
provinces today driven by the highly
transmissible omicron variant the
dangerous surge comes as many students
prepare to head back to class next week
several provinces are extending winter
breaks while others scramble to finalize
plans as heather urex west reports it's
all having a major effect on parents
right across the country
with a new baby and an eight-year-old
itching to get back to school calgary
mom lauren fairweather is anxious to
know whether kids in alberta will be
heading back to class next week as
planned it's really heartbreaking every
time
we get told we're going back to online
or
don't get to be
in school
with our friends
and it's tiring
the alberta government has not yet
announced its plans for students next
week though most other provinces are
opting to keep kids home even if it's
just for a couple more days students
will be returning to school in-person
learning on wednesday january 5th 2022
this will provide our schools with extra
time to begin to put in place additional
health and safety measures including
deploying additional masking options for
students and educators and further
improving air ventilation in schools
unions like the elementary teachers
federation of ontario have been
advocating for improved masks including
the distribution of n95s for teachers at
the same time there is a very strong
desire on the part of members to be
where we belong which is in schools
teaching our students students will be
returning to in-person learning across
most of the country but in several
regions they'll have to wait an extra
week we're not closing schools we're not
going to online learning what we're
doing is having a phased
approach to full back to school the
winter break has now been extended in bc
manitoba quebec nova scotia prince
edward island and the northwest
territories while students in
newfoundland and labrador are set to
move to online learning next week i
think as long as it's a short delay the
goal of which would be to make the
school environment safer
then that's a prudent step but we need
to get the kids back to school as soon
as we can i think that at the very bare
minimum our kids need to be able to go
to school after nearly two years of
covet uncertainty parents students and
teachers forced to navigate yet another
wave heather urex west global news
calgary
ontario is also updating its testing
guidelines and shortening the isolation
period for some residents people with
cover 19 who are fully vaccinated and
children under 12 will now be required
to isolate for five days provided their
symptoms have improved and starting
tomorrow pcr tests will only be
available for symptomatic high-risk
individuals and those who work in the
highest risk settings the province will
also offer fourth doses of mrna vaccines
to seniors in congregate care settings
who had their third shot at least three
months prior
ontario is just one of the provinces
loosening isolation periods for those
who test positive to help prevent the
system from collapsing the public health
agency of canada is reporting a 141
percent increase in new cases over the
last week hospitalizations from the
omicron variant are relatively low but
copenhagen infections and precautions
are forcing many people off the job
including in health care ross lord
reports
with covet 19 cases overwhelming
ontario's testing capacity more people
are turning to emergency departments
like this one in oakville a lot of
people coming in because they can't
access the resources but in addition our
numbers are going up people are feeling
a little bit disheartened by it
and i think it's it's over exhausting a
lot of the systems but rules forcing
health care workers to isolate if
they've tested positive or been exposed
to the virus are leaving fewer staff to
respond we are noticing that it is
depleting some of our staff in that
capacity in manitoba 418 healthcare
workers tested positive in one week
that's about seven times more than the
previous week to prevent a collapse of
the health care system provinces are
starting to loosen the rules in quebec
where 12 000 health care workers are at
home some who've tested positive will be
allowed to stay on the job now other
provinces are reducing isolation periods
we are also going to reduce the
self-isolation period following a
positive test whether it's a pcr test or
a a rapid test
from from 10 days down to five days to
ensure
sufficient staffing levels
workers have the opportunity to return
to work after isolating for seven days
based on a negative pcr test on day six
or two negative rat tests at day six and
seven
american authorities reduced isolation
periods this week but the public health
agency of canada says for now it's not
changing its recommendation and some in
the health care system say any move that
could increase contact between the
contagious and the vulnerable should not
be taken lightly i struggle to see where
that's a good idea
and that would also mean someone showing
up to work at soby's sick
someone that doesn't have a union to
speak for them i think that um
i think that if you're sick you should
be able to stay home what's to stop us
from just basically opening everything
up and saying
hey we don't need to isolate like where
do we draw the line here
with pandemic conditions continually
changing finding the best response is
still elusive
ross lord global news
nova scotia is also expanding
eligibility for booster shots starting
monday people aged 30 and older can
start booking their third shots the
province is also adding more clinics to
deliver vaccinations and is appealing to
anyone with experience giving shots to
help nova scotia is also recommending
people use three layer masks whether
non-medical or cloth
in quebec a nighttime curfew will be in
effect starting tomorrow the curfew will
run from 10 p.m until 5 a.m for at least
the next three weeks fines starting at
one thousand dollars will be in place
for anyone not at home without a good
reason during that time and people must
work from home if they can
shops will be closed on sundays and
indoor dining at restaurants and
gatherings in homes will not be allowed
with pediatric hospitalization
skyrocketing in the u.s the fda is
expected to announce approval of
pfizer's booster shot for 12 to 15 year
olds on monday and while a quieter
countdown to 2022 has begun time is
standing still for thousands of
travelers stuck at u.s airports
including those flying westjet jennifer
johnson reports
across america there is little cheer as
city officials put the brakes on new
year's eve celebrations
atlanta's annual peach drop has been
dropped as the omicron variant tears
through that region it's the best
interest of the city to keep everyone
safe as possible
los angeles san francisco seattle and
kansas city are among a growing list of
places telling revelers to stay home i
know that people are anxious to get back
to a sense of normal
but we have to remember that we are
still in the middle of a global pandemic
it is called it is not over
the crystal ball drop in new york city
will go on but with one quarter of the
crowd everyone has to wear masks and
show proof of vaccination as 2021 comes
to a close the centers for disease
control is reporting its highest level
of new daily covet 19 cases ever with
omicron we are going to see a viral
blizzard over the next five to eight
weeks in this country real blizzards in
several western states and covent 19
attacking airline workers are making for
the perfect storm grounding planes and
passengers thousands have been stranded
at airports while bad weather is again
in the forecast 20 million americans are
under severe weather alerts not being
with my parents for new year's eve don't
make me cry
westjet delta united jetblue alaska
airlines and others are canceling
flights and trimming routes i just want
to get home unfortunately travel experts
say that simple request may be hard to
deliver for the next several days we can
expect this to continue through the
holiday season through the new year and
it probably will not let up until the
actual travel rush lets up going home is
also getting difficult for thousands of
passengers aboard cruise ships the queen
mary 2 has delayed its return to the
port of new york after a covet 19
outbreak that ship is among almost 90
the cdc is now monitoring
jennifer johnson global news washington
just like north america countries across
europe are breaking records for daily
coveted cases france confirmed more than
200 000 new infections today for a
second day in a row it's now introducing
some controversial new measures to stop
the rapid spread of the omicron variant
and when it comes to deaths russia has
now overtaken brazil second only to the
u.s redmond shannon reports on the dire
situation
peeking out from its scaffolding big ben
is preparing for 2022 while undergoing
renovation but london like most of
europe will not be ringing in the new
year as normal the uk france and spain
alone posting almost half a million new
covet 19 cases in a day the real numbers
thought to be much higher as testing
measures struggle to keep up
we do recognize that there are some
difficulties across the country both
with pharmacies
and with home testing
requests in italy test centers are also
overloaded
this woman says she spent five hours in
line
in france where more than two people are
being infected every second lineups too
for vaccines
this doctor says the current wave is
spurring the previously vaccine hesitant
to come for their first shot
french movie theaters serve their last
scoops of popcorn before eating and
drinking in cinemas is banned and paris
is controversially making masks
mandatory outdoors starting friday
this woman among those who think it's a
pointless move
in central and eastern europe however
many infection curves are tilting down
but authorities in countries like
germany and russia warn omicron's spread
is only beginning despite russian case
numbers being low deaths have hovered
around a thousand a day its official
pandemic death toll now overtaking
brazil and in poland which like russia
has high rates of vaccine hesitancy the
effects of last month's spike now
apparent it has reported more than 700
deaths for the second day running
redmond shannon global news london
caught up in a crackdown on dissent
coming up why two journalists are facing
charges in hong kong
in hong kong two former editors of an
online pro-democracy news outlet have
been charged with sedition and denied
bail the charges come a day after the
shutdown of stan news and the arrest of
some of its staff including canadian
singer and activist denise ho she was
released from police custody today hong
kong leader carrie lamb defended the
raid part of a wider crackdown on
dissent in the semi-autonomous city
seditious acts and activities
and inciting
other people through public access
activities could not be condoned
under the guise of news reporting
stand was the most prominent remaining
pro-democracy publication in hong kong
i had the difficult first year of joe
biden's presidency and the trouble that
looms
you're watching global national
[Music]
governor general mary simon is looking
ahead to 2022 with optimism for
canadians in her first new year's
message since becoming vice regal in
july simon says canadians have shown
resilience despite a difficult year
in inuktitut there is a concept called
ayunita
although it means commitment a promise
a vow
it's also so much more we find meaning
in its action
simon delivered her new year's message
in english french and
the surge in covet 19 cases in the
united states has in many ways defined
the first year of joe biden's presidency
the virus has derailed his central
promise to bring the pandemic under
control while biden's approval ratings
have already plummeted things could get
worse for the democratic party as
midterm elections loom jackson proskow
reports
on the steps of the very building that
had come under attack just two weeks
prior
joseph robinette joe biden was sworn in
as the 46th president of the united
states delivering a promise to restore
faith in government this is democracy's
day
a day of history and hope yet biden's
first year has instead been overshadowed
by setbacks political strife and the
unrelenting crush of the pandemic a lot
of unfortunate things have happened in
his first year many of which he had no
real control over i'll shut down the
virus
bringing kovid 19 under control was a
central campaign promise for biden
the day he took office the u.s death
toll from the pandemic stood at 500
thousand
vaccines delivered optimism it would all
end soon
biden even declared july 4th
independence day from the virus we are
emerging
from the darkness of
years
a year pandemic and isolation year of
pain
fear and heartbreaking loss the delta
and omicron variants had other plans so
did biden's republican opponents they've
sent a message to say you know what get
vaccinated but it really ain't going to
do anything for you protect us don't
inject us they sowed discord over
vaccines and vaccination mandates
suddenly the country that oversaw the
development of vaccines was left lagging
behind the world in vaccination rates
while deaths soared past eight hundred
thousand all of the disinformation and
misinformation has become very
problematic people don't know who to
trust who to turn to
uh and and we're going to have to do a
lot of work to repair that in the future
the biden administration had its own
missteps on pandemic messaging promising
booster shots for everyone before
regulators had approved them
just 53 percent of americans now approve
of his response to the pandemic down 20
points from the start of the year
navigating a completely new virus with
changing epidemiology changing virology
and a changing political landscape is
extremely complicated
on the political front biden's domestic
agenda has been sidelined by the
realities of a slim majority in congress
his 4 trillion dollar infrastructure and
social spending package has been
derailed key issues like voting rights
legislation have stalled as moderate
democrats refuse to back the biden
agenda
[Music]
while republican hardliners loyalists to
former president donald trump continue
to push lies about a stolen election
undermining biden's legitimacy the
biggest factor that has really made
governing difficult for biden has been
the thing that he promised to bring
which was unity
the chaotic and sudden u.s withdrawal
from afghanistan only furthered
perceptions of an administration in free
fall even though biden was adhering to a
departure plan set by trump biden has
paid dearly in the polls his overall
approval rating has sunk from a high of
57 percent in january to 42 percent
today
there are just so many things that have
made
biden less popular because americans
thought they were voting for competence
and normality and
solutions yet if there's one overarching
issue dragging biden down it's the
economy and rising consumer prices
the number one issue was the economy and
inflation and it really comes down to
making people's lives better inflation
is at its highest level since 1990. the
supply chain crunch has only added to
his woes and biden's agenda hasn't yet
delivered relief to millions of
middle-class voters despite
record-setting job creation look at my
presidency so far
it's a jobs presidency
and it's a small business presidency it
all suggests trouble ahead for the
president and his party democrats are
eyeing substantial losses in the 2022
midterms when republicans are likely to
regain control of the house and possibly
the senate republicans are likely to use
any newfound majority to launch
congressional investigations and stoke
the culture wars yet biden also has a
chance to turn things around the next
year will prove crucial for salvaging
his presidency and his legacy even if
the lessons from his first year suggest
it may be largely decided by factors
beyond his control
jackson frost go global news washington
[Music]
up next a dog's new life how an edmonton
woman is teaching old dogs new tricks
dogs bring joy to the lives of so many
of us they even make our daily routines
a little healthier often forcing us to
get outdoors but an edmonton woman has
flipped the script she's given not one
but two abandoned and overweight dogs a
new home and helped them get back to a
healthy weight seracomadina explains
woody knows he's a good-looking old dog
are you more handsome
yeah he's a massive malamute but not
like before this big boy has dropped a
whopping 100 pounds almost 210. yeah
they actually weighed him on a cattle
scale when they when they got him in in
lethbridge june 2020 woody was found
abandoned in a muddy creek in cole dale
he appeared to be drowning you know
woody was 11 when we got him and i can't
imagine
after 11 years been going huh okay i'm
done now the rescue turned to pam hagee
an edmonton woman who helped another big
old boy over 200 pounds between them
it's about 205 pounds that they've lost
where you go
here's kai what a boy in 2018 his owners
left him at a clinic to be put down he
weighed
173 pounds he could barely stand hagie
changed his life i can't believe
someone didn't love him enough to keep
him kai is bonded with hagee he loves
going to the dog park and long walks he
also has a job are you excited to be a
therapy dog
you ready to go
you kind of stick with them through
thick and thin and these guys literally
through thick and thin
as for woody it was believed he would be
great on an acreage but it didn't work
out he doesn't listen he does whatever
he wants and i remember thinking who has
a malamute in this city like literally
who has a malamute in the city but i do
hege was only supposed to foster these
two but kai fit in so well are you
hungry
in november it was clear woody would
also be added to the pack even if
sometimes he gets a little desperate for
snacks i always thought of myself more
as a puppy person but
boy these two old boys really stole my
heart
these dogs spent years unable to really
move
now they have a safe and healthy place
to live out their golden ears
sarah comedina global news
gotta love old dogs that's global
national for this thursday night i'm
colleen christie tonight's your canada
is quincy the dog on a snowy trail in
winnipeg there are beautiful shots all
over canada please email yours to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching sonya diehl will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow take care of
yourselves and happy new year